Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie black flash hype
we have to talk about legends of tomorrow.
Their are lot of you that said you are having
trouble finding the show depending on the
country that you live and be sure to check
online for where to watch legends of tomorrow
so that we can talk about it every week.
Remember, it's on Tuesday nights Now in the
United States and you should be able to find
it relatively quickly.
But there is a new flash ring giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment about the episode on this
video and we have a whole bunch of reverse
flash black flash flash family speed force
stuff to talk about.
Really twisted Everyone's head around a little
with explaining how eobard Thawne is survived
from the flash season one finale when Eddie
killed himself, but it is coming back on the
flash so try to explain everything solicitous
a little bit different than a normal top 10
video just because black flash was such a
big deal in this episode there was a lot of
stuff going on but he was really like the
go to thing that everybody was asking about.
He was a character that was introduced during
the Wally West run before Barry Allen came
back by Grant Morrison and Mark Muller they
had like a very short run on the flash where
they basically turned Wally into this god
of speed into this crazy storyline with them.
So when you hear stories about Wally being
able to do all these crazy things like travel
to the edge of the universe and back in an
instant travel faster than teleporting that
came during their run, which is kind of lost
in the continuity because then Geoff John's
came on the title he sort of rewrote how the
black flash works Barry Allen became the black
flash for a brief period during rebirth when
the reverse flash poisoned him with the negative
speed force sort of reversed his polarity.
Remember the speed force obeys certain electrical
properties.
So there's a positive electron charge.
There's a negative electron charge.
So there is such a thing is the negative speed
force the TV show just hasn't gotten into
that yet.
But during their really brief run Grant Morrison
and Mark Bullard introduce this character
to challenge Wally West, where he basically
learned to out run death he was running from
his own death, is this really weird metaphysical
idea that Geoff John's turned and more of
a practical thing like the black flash is
an actual physical entity that will kill you
if he catches up to you anything that he touches.
So you can't let them touch you.
There's a villain on the flash next week that's
giving them an important lesson for how to
fight that.
So I did a trailer video for that all at a
link at the end of this the TV show version
of the black flash is pretty close to the
comics but if you remember during the flash
season two finale the time wraiths came in
change zoom into the black flash, so now anything
that was left of Hunter Solomon is completely
gone.
He is fully black flash.
Now he might not even remember if you call
them out by name, but they might address that
when he goes in the flash TV show he can smell
the speed force he's just as fast if not faster
than the reverse flash was one of the fastest
speedsters that we know about any sort of
a supercharged version of the time wraiths
something much, much worse.
The reason they brought him back to legends
of tomorrow first before bringing him back
to the flash is all because of eobard Thawne
story.
They explained during season two how eobard
Thawne survived he was protected by the speed
force.
When he was traveling back to find out where
Barry Allen lived in time, he had been the
enemy of the flash but he didn't know where
Barry Allen came from.
So they surmise that the speed force protected
him when Eddie Thawne killed himself killing
the wells version of eobard Thawne cut to
season 3 Barry's created flashpoint he's time
travel many times going up against the time
wraiths and.
A lot of people are like wait a minute.
How come the reverse flash and time travel
this much without getting into trouble with
the time wraiths, so this is the explainer
one he knows what's coming for him.
So he knows how to stay one step ahead with
to the way they explain it retroactively is
that he's been running this whole time he
hasn't been getting away Scott free.
It just that we haven't seen those moments.
So it has this whole effect of leveling the
playing field within the Legion of doom because
why would a speedster need the help of two
former members of the league of assassins
I totally love the way they came together
in this episode they just kept making fun
of each other.
You're dead in the future you only have one
hand were to members who used to be part of
the league of assassins even though I'm the
only one the got to be rage, but it just proves
how awesome the villains are this season so
this is why I am hoping so much that they
get the Spear of destiny and eobard Thawne
as he explains his plan fixes the fact that
he's a time aberration.
So he will continue to exist in the flash
arrow universe and what that might mean is
that he'll end up bringing Eddie back to life.
But the beauty of the spear is a macguffin
they sort of made fun of that in the last
episode the spirit is a matter just to make
up and it just an object that everybody's
going for.
So the really awesome thing for the writers
is is that because it's so powerful they don't
have to explain everything that he can do
so they can bring Eddie back using the Spear
they can just have eobard Thawne fixed time
so that he can continue to exist and then
the other thing is using it to get rid of
Barry Allen without getting rid of the speed
force in general.
So there still a couple really big concepts
from the comics that the TV shows haven't
fully explain like the true nature of the
speed force because in a couple different
versions of the comic book Barry is had different
relationships.
There's a version of the comics.
The Geoff John's wrote before flashpoint where
he creates the speed force himself he sort
of like a battery.
So when Barry Allen dies the speed force goes
away but then there are other versions of
the comics where the speed force is just always
been there, so there's still lots of questions
that the TV shows will explain in future seasons.
So the whole idea is that the villains themselves
are time aberrations they're going to use
the Spear to fix that.
But it also mirrors what's going on with the
heroes storyline the legends, so I loved all
their scenes, but Martin Stein's daughter
was amazing the actors the place is great.
I hope she comes back a bunch more in it sounds
like what's going to happen is is that they'll
come to the conclusion that some changes to
the timeline are okay some time aberrations
or find they don't have to be absolutely strict
about it logically, leaving the door open
for eobard Thawne fix his situation so that
he doesn't have to go away forever because
the reverse flash is the greatest enemy of
the flash.
You can't get rid of him villains like that
never die, but there's always some big twist
as to how they get defeated and are able to
slink away to fight another day, so this sounds
like what it's going to be the heroes make
some mistakes themselves and decide that hey
you know, this is okay.
My daughter deserves to exist.
So logically you can understand how eobard
Thawne will be able to fix his time aberration
because under the normal rules the time Masters
would go after him in a race his aberration.
So he would cease to exist.
So this leaves a lot of questions about what's
going to happen with.
The Legion of doom in season two because they
as a group works so well together so I'm really
hoping that at least some of them come back
I really want.
The reverse flash to come back Jon Barrowman,
so is fantastic and all her scenes.
Neal McDonough know as Damien Darhk is so
much more fun on this show that he was on
arrow even made fun of arrow season four 2016
wasn't my best year I aim to change that he
was basically taking a big dig at that whole
season.
So really like the only plot hole I saw was
that Barry had not fully explained eobard
Thawne to all the people like they didn't
know who he was told Martin Stein piped up,
but overall it was a great episode.
Some of you said that you liked it even more
than you like the flash if it seems like the
legends plot is moving a lot faster is because
they have fewer episodes I think I said in
the last legends video that I posted they
only have 17 episodes this season that might
get up for season three.
They've Artie been renewed for season three.
But they haven't confirmed who's coming back
in with the storylines going to be is a whole
bunch of stuff we won't find out to the season
finale usually they tease what's going to
be happening in the first episode of the next
season.
The rip hunter twist at the end is just them.
Basically, turning an evil by editing his
memories.
So that's why he looks like he's assassinating
Gen. Washington before he becomes President
of the United States.
So is gonna be a lot of fun I totally loved
that they're letting Arthur Darvill be so
different in all these different episodes.
The other big thing they tease.
It's coming up is the Capt. cold is coming
back to the show.
They didn't say which episode relatively quickly
in the black flash is.
I said is going to go guest star on the flash
relatively soon as well, but they didn't say
exactly which episode what's happening later
tonight is that arrow is selecting its new
black canary they tease her at the end of
the last episode, so be sure to check that
out.
It should be pretty interesting the way they
explain her character and how she's gonna
fit into the team she's a metahuman Black
Canary.
So is getting way more comic book he and just
because everybody seems kind of burnt out
on DC movie videos I'll be doing some new
Marvel movie stuff as well as game of thrones
in Star Wars tomorrow.
So whole bunch awesome stuff coming in the
next couple days.
Congratulations to the new flash ring giveaway
winner Gryphyn Karimloo please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details.
There was a new round that started in this
video so I'll announce the winner when I post
that arrow video later tonight while you wait
for that click here for the flash episode
and click here for the flash trailer thank
you so much watching everybody let's high
five I'll see in the next video!